I I heard it's great I want to watch it
I'm also a huge fan of Maddie mat yeah
I'm a huge fan of that guy I love his
cooking there he's pretty cool he's a
guy I want to be friends with Matty
maton if you're watching or listening we
know that you are uh we're big fans uh
come on over to the Pod we we like you
in our life as a potentially a real life
friend I would love to have him on this
podcast you kidding me so who knows
Matty mat I I I probably bet we know
somebody once removed or something I
watched that guy make pancakes once it
was nuts
[Laughter]
take take us through
it he just made these these pancakes
when he when he mixed the batter look at
those pancakes dude I've just never seen
pancakes like this in my life oh